[Music]
that's the Star Wars song now so I guess
I gotta sing that at the beginning
alright so a new trailer we have a new
trailer for Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker it's like the second teaser
trailer the rise of Skywalker has half
of the trailer shows old footage of the
old movies with voice over and then the
other half shows a lot of walking and
staring this trailer does pull a lot
from the Revenge of the Sith teaser
trailer maybe that's why I feels like a
teaser trailer my first half is old
footage with voiceover second half you
know the music swells I know you want me
to talk about evil Rey right now I'm
gonna talk about evil Reina you have to
talk about the other important things
which is this the Kaiser Sousa moment
you see c-3po with the red eyes is this
where we find is this the reveal to
c-3po gonna be like oh my must live but
in reality the most logical reason c-3po
has red eyes action figures baby yeah
Threepio with a silver leg you have
Threepio with the red arm but do you
have Threepio with the red eyes nope
well time to drop more money on those
hot toys baby that's why that's why they
change up the look of characters for the
next movies because will the action
figures now different you don't have
that action figure you need to buy that
action figure now that's why there's
like 9000 Iron Man suits out there's cuz
it's like well I don't have that one for
that movie there's also this scene where
this like this clouds and lightning in
space which looks a lot like the castle
run from so low a Star Wars story which
I hope it's not the Kessel run first of
all why would you go back to the castle
run second of all you know if this is
the Kessel run they're gonna do
something and then at the very end of
the movie someone's gonna be like hey by
the way that castle run you did in less
than 11 parsecs like alright so Han Solo
doesn't even get to keep that anymore so
let's just not make that the castle also
of note a laser that strikes the ground
is that another Death Star please don't
be another desktop
I've always felt for the force awakens
at work because you need to remind
people hey we totally we remember old
Star Wars just like that Death Star so I
got where they were coming from with
that and that's something you do if
you're playing it safe is you have the
weapon from the other movie but now it's
kind of different but not but okay we're
past that now let's not have another
death laser that hits worlds which means
they're totally go I mean obviously the
death stars in it so there is that oh
god it's not like there's a new Death
Star but they don't have the Kyber
crystal which I guess was in the center
of the Death Star so now they have to go
find the Kyber crystal that was in the
old Death Star and now they have a new
Death Star [ __ ]
I hope that's not it
to this trailer we get the hook the hook
is evil Ray Ray might turn evil Ray's
not gonna turn evil and that bums me out
that I feel that ways cuz it's like it's
not even teasing me I don't have the
possibility of Ray turning evil because
at this point it's just it's not in her
character to do so after the force
awakens going into the last Jedi I
always thought the best arc that could
have done with ray is turn ray evil it's
a time to set that up would have been
the last Jedi and they just didn't set
any of that out any time Ray is kind of
tempted with the dark side she shuts it
down any time kylo ren's like hey join
me to rule the galaxy she shuts that
down in fact her draw to kylo Ren other
than her seeing him without a shirt was
oh there's good in him I need to turn
him good and at the end she shuts the
door on that and that's that like she
turned her back on evil so her turning
bad in this movie I just I just don't
see that happening because they didn't
set that up yeah there's that one
throwaway line from Luke where Luke's
like he went right to the darkness you
didn't even question it or something
like that but none of her actions back
that up so it's just like it's a line
that's meaningless it's like they want
us to by the possibility that Ray's
gonna turn bad but they were always
afraid to get her hands dirty or
something like that you have to get your
character's hands dirty you have to give
them grit you have to make them flawed
like say what you want about Episode two
and I have said a lot and it can still
wiped out a camp of Tusken Raiders
including children he did that he has
that like no one can take that from him
and even his flip was too abrupt in
Episode three so if that flip was too
abrupt how crazy out of character would
this flip be which if Ray does turn bad
and there are some people who rage out
about it you know if there she turns bad
and people are like this is [ __ ]
that's against her character can we just
see that as the Olive Branch moment you
know it's like wait what having the
eternal optimist who showed they have
faith that the villain actually still
has good in them taking that character
and making them an [ __ ] version of
themselves it's completely out of
character and leaves a bad taste in your
mouth might ruin the experience yep now
you got it now we can all say we
understand where we're all coming from a
week and I'll just shake hands now
I guess the Internet's not that simple
you see they're a force vision a robot
or a clone or an excuse to have a new
action figure
evil ray coming soon from Hot Toys for
300 bucks and also the biggest reason
she's not gonna turn bad is because if
she was gonna turn bad that's the kind
of reveal you don't spoil then your
trailer let's number
one right there this is the biggest
reason I'm like probably not so all this
stacks up for me being like that that's
a neat tease in a trailer but it did
nothing for me like when I watched the
trailer I was like no which is a bummer
but that's this kind of what happened
with the last Jedi swear Star Wars left
us off like part of the Star Wars
experience a big part of the Star Wars
experience was always going into the new
movie speculating about things wondering
where it's gonna go the last Jedi just
cut it off it didn't leave us with that
speculative string we didn't have
anywhere to go with it so we haven't
really speculated about it I mean some
have I haven't my friends and I aren't
speculating talking about Star Wars like
we would or we used to we're just
waiting for it to happen so in the end
the second teaser trailer for the rise
of Skywalker it was a good taster
trailer again didn't blow my socks off I
actually watched this weekend I watched
all of the Star Wars trailers from the
prequels on anyway because again wasn't
ever around for trailers for the old
trilogy except for the re-releases in 97
but you know prequel prequels on like
all the trailers just blew your mind to
blow your teeth out you're like ah you
just wanted to think about it and talk
about it rise your skyrocket trailers
have been pretty vague it pretty simple
we don't really know much about it which
on one hand I'm like great you're not
spoiling the movie also I know you're
not spoiling the movie so those we don't
know the logistics of Palpatine coming
back is he a clone is he an evil force
ghost so we do know that Jedi force
ghosts do have matter because they sit
on logs and they bonk you on the heads
that they can touch things ergo they can
possibly fight things we just have Luke
fight the Emperor why not just throw
that at the screen might as well have
that Hail Mary attempt for people who
are disappointed in the last Jedi to
bleed gosh anyhow glad to know that evil
c-3po was behind it all so then the
trailer for Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker have you seen it what did you
think about it and do you think Rey is
actually gonna turn back whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]